this is a production of Cornell
University
so today I would like to talk about the
fact that P's can be used as a model
plant as they were many many years ago
before the miserable little weed into
interjected itself but there are things
you can do with peas that you can't do
with a rabbit abscess because of its
core line or stem nature but I would
like today to talk about the modern
findings in peas and there's so we can
be his the subject but the reason I got
into this again was actually because of
professor emeritus Chris Wayne that
those of you who are long-term members
in the department will know well well
Chris called me up a couple of years ago
and he said under revising my vegetable
crop physiology book and I need somebody
to write the chapter on peas I said no
way Chris unretired forget about it
so he went away he then came back a year
later in other words about a year ago
and said Peter the guy who was going to
do it has failed to produce I really
need a chapter on peas I said ok so I
had to do a lot of research on peas in
the literature to bring myself up to
date and even though I work on piece my
graduate work my postdoc work a lot of
my career I have wasn't up to date but
as I spent months getting up to date I
thought I would share the knowledge I
gained so garden peas we know them as
garden peas but they can also be crops
and Oh most of you probably if you don't
grow them in your garden you probably
know them just from a supermarket
freezing chest but the peas are grown as
one of the major crops not up with the
big corn and soybeans but their major
crop in many countries so here's the
global he
production and we can divide peas into
green peas and dry peas so here is the
amount of metric tons the area at the
the top we have green peas interestingly
China is by way and above anybody else
as the main producer of green peas dry
peas produce a large tonnage as well and
for that Canada is the main producer of
dry peas but then you might ask the
difference what's the difference between
field peas and dry peas and the main
difference is that garden sorry garden
peas and field dried peas is that garden
peas have a higher sugar content and
those the ones we get as frozen peas and
field peas which produce dry peas have a
much higher starch and low sugar content
and if you have a tourist in British
parks you're offered something with
mushy peas mushy bees are dried peas
rehydrated and dried green and they are
a British delicacy interestingly most
field production at field scale weather
for fresh peas or dry peas uses leafless
peas these are peas with no leaves they
just have tendrils and stipules and the
reason these are used is they don't have
to be staked they hold themselves up in
a vast mass if you put normal peas in a
field without so many tendrils they just
fall over they rot they can't be
harvested so this is he production and
this is then combined there is the
production of green peas in Italy
with the combine and here are dry peas
being combined in Canada now the story
of the importance of peas to biology of
course really begins with Gregor Mendel
and there is a portrait of Gregor Mendel
holding his favorite plant a pea and one
of the main genes that I worked on in
this is the tall P versus dwarf pea and
we are pretty sure that their lines that
we worked on the same has worked on by
Mendel because we have pretty good
records of what was being grown at that
time now Mendel was a monk an
Augustinian monk in an abbey in what was
then called Brune in in the
austro-hungarian Empire and it's now
called Bruno in the Czech Republic
so graduate students can you recognize
who on that is Gregor Mendel anybody
like to suggest you stick your hand up
and describe where he is okay very good
sake however look at the jealousy of the
surrounding bones now I trust when you
go to the dining hall you get these
looks of jealousy because you are
working on plants which makes you the
most interesting graduate students
around
however we then have to ask the question
here what is he holding so there's an
enlargement of that what do you think
he's holding he's not holding a pea plum
look at the flowers
fuchsia fuchsia Thank You Nina he's
holding a fuchsia just happened in that
photograph he was holding a fuchsia and
of course Mendel is very famous for his
original rules of genetics and I'm sure
you're more familiar with this from high
school but here are the modern mem
Mendel's these are the current P
researchers will actually Ian Murphy is
retired and these I know everybody on
this one except they have never met no
Ellis these three are University of
Tasmania there has been a close
cooperation between Cornell and Tasmania
in Murphy did a sabbatical up at Geneva
in the nineteen seventies Jim read below
did two sabbaticals at Cornell and is a
good friend of mine I did acid to
sabbaticals in his lab Jim Walla is
probably the most noted pea geneticist
at the present time I better say P
molecular biologist because genetics has
moved on he's us more of the sequencing
and g9 in piece and anybody else know LS
work worked on the molecular biology of
leaf formation Christine beverage worked
out the control of branching and she's
at University of Queensland and Jocelyn
Oscar in Alberta works on seed
biogenesis here are all Mendel's genes I
don't have time to go over every one but
if anybody wants any of this data it
will be in two places a these slides are
being saved and secondly the Chris
Wayne's book on vegetable crop
physiology comes out next spring that's
all whoopsie and it's
all in there so error Mendel's genes or
the traits here are the and the
different phenotypes here is what we
know the genes are the here is the
change at the molecular level but there
are still three genes that mental work
on we don't know really what they are
but many of the others we know round
versus wrinkled all versus dwarf etc P
has a standard hyper Geel germination
which would be quite familiar with they
in the dark the seedling stems grow much
taller than in the light light causes a
very pronounced decrease in elongation
and if they're growing normally in soil
near two or three inches under you get
this chute that comes up through the
soil the apical bud is hooked and was
one of the classic it's a research
involving ethylene the epical hook and
when you put it in the light the apical
hook unfolds and you get the generation
of the expanded leaves now here's some
work by one of my graduate students Fred
bérenger and what he was doing was
tracking the growth rate of the stems
second-by-second
with a very sensitive system and looking
at the changing growth when you turn on
the light so up this side we have the
growth rate on the bottom we have hours
after exposure and the light came on at
zero here's the result of exposing them
to red light blue light or white
fluorescent light here's where the light
was turned on and you get a drop in the
growth rate within about a minute a very
precise very rapid response if you if
that occurs in white light or blue light
if you have red light the response takes
at least an hour to an hour and a half
before it shows any effect and then
following about three or four hours the
growth rate recovers to 2a certainly a
lower rate than the dark but it does
have some recovery after going with blue
and white light almost down to zero for
a couple of hours now what is
interesting is what happens if you give
the the seedlings a pulse of light so we
tried that and so they here they got a
pulse of eight second fluorescent and
you get this immediate drop but if
you've only left the light on for eight
seconds the growth then goes back to the
dark rate and then if an hour and a half
drops again so this is dissected out
very nicely the fact there are two
different receptors here cryptochrome
picks up the blue light and has a very
rapid effect phytochrome picks up the
red light but doesn't produce any effect
on growth till about an hour and a half
what we find is that
the regulation of the growth rate
depends on the level of gibberellin
particularly gibberellin number one and
if you take a dark room P and measure
the chipper L in content this is the
chipper L in content
Inlet that here's the level in the dark
after four hours of light you have to
give it enough to see these changes
measuring gibberellin the level drops
and it stays there and then the level
goes way up in the light now we have
already told you the growth in the light
is much less than the dark so how can
this be well what if this was just
looking for the sensitivity to
gibberellin dwarf peas were taken and
treated with an extract
sorry treated with gibberellins to see
how they would respond and dark grown
seedlings respond a large amount however
after after they have been in the light
for just one day they are much less
responsive to gibberellin and in
constant light they are also less
responsive so what we are having when
the light comes on first of all there is
a rapid drop in the responsiveness to
gibberellin for the gibberellin signal
transduction chain then the level of
gibberellin actually Falls then the
sensitivity stays low as the level of G
burrowing goes back on and that reflects
very nicely that instant drop and then a
few hours later the growth rate comes up
someone
peas have been used to look at a
chloroplast changes as the plants come
into the light and this is just a few
pictures so here's the results of some
electron micrographs looking at the
chloroplasts in these peas and this is
in darkness and here you see the changes
8 hours
3 3 days later and you see the membrane
starting to form and then in the fourth
day you see the membranes looking much
more like a typical chloroplast and a
thorough analysis was done this is
enlarged just enlargements of each one
and so what we find is that some of the
photosynthesis components are actually
present in the seed or the seedling the
dark brown seedling others only appear
after the light has been turned on or
the plants move into the light now I
spend quite a bit of time in my career
looking at pea internode length and here
we have again Mendel's peas the tall
penis is the dwarf pea if we look at the
difference in growth rate I should point
out the difference is not the number of
nodes it's the length of each internode
so this now looks at the infinate
lengths are in the the y axis an inter
node number on the lower axis as you can
see the info nodes Duke over as the
plant grows they do get slightly longer
but they peak out at a very big
difference
this is millimeters so about 4
this sorry this is about 4 centimeters 3
to 4 centimeters here for the dwarf and
about 15 centimeters for the tall big
difference so what is the reason for
this
well what my colleagues and I discovered
in way back we're talking about the
1980s is that the crucial difference is
that dwarf plants have a very low
content of gibberellin number one tall
plants have a high content of
gibberellin number one and the crucial
difference is the transfer from the
precursor of gibberellin number one to
jibril number one and the precursor is
chipper Allen number 20 gee a 20 and the
difference between GA 20 and GA 1 is
simply one hydroxyl group GA 20 it's not
cherry 20 here is inactive in growth it
doesn't have any effect on growth GA 1
is the growth active gibberellin and
there is an enzyme that puts on this
hydroxyl group and it's called ga ga 3
beta hydroxylase or more recently
they've just renamed it GA 3 oxidase and
it is called that because as the
numbering of the carbons in this
molecule this is carbon number 3 so it's
just the addition of one hydroxyl makes
all the difference between a tall and a
dwarf they both have GA 1 a dwarf has a
low level a tall has a high level so my
colleagues and I then were able to
isolate the gene involved this is 20
something years ago 20
22 years ago so a lot of this is history
we were able to isolate the gene and
show that it was just one difference in
the gene a single base change if you
between Aegean and a that this led to a
change in one amino acid and this single
amino acid change made all the
difference as to whether the enzyme
gibberellin 3 beta hydroxylase had high
activity or very low activity and to
show this we then put the gene into the
bacteria E coli ecoli doesn't normally
make gibberellin but when you put the
gene in it will take the G a 20 and it
will convert it to GA 1 so we did this
with the gene from the tall plant and
the gene from the dwarf plant and then
looked at how much metabolism if you
then fed CA 22 the bacterium we asked
how much GA 1 would it make and here is
the result this this is high-performance
liquid chromatography this is the amount
of radioactivity this is the position
where GA 20 comes off GA 1 comes off
much earlier off the column and so here
is the conversion of GA 22 GA 1 in tall
plants and here is the conversion of GA
22 GA 1 in dwarf plants neatly showing
that indeed we were correct that the
enzyme the mutant enzyme in the dwarf
plant is much less active in this
transition
so here is the pathway for gibberellin
biosynthesis and the last step is down
here GA 22 GA 1 the gene is des where
was designated le for length and there's
the enzyme and that's what Mendel was
working on some hundred and forty fifty
hundred and sixty years ago but he
didn't know what he was working on at
that level but it makes a very nice
story
now they returned out to be there are a
whole lot of length mutants and these
these were this an artist grew these
from peas I grow in the greenhouses here
this is an extreme dwarf which is called
Nana
this is Mendel's dwarf
this is mandals tall and the last one is
a super tall and this super tall turns
out to have a mutation in the
gibberellin signal transduction chain
now be with regard to chipper allen and
orcs in and many other controls in
development the the now with no effect
in this case is tall when you have
there's a signal transduction component
which we called Ella and Ella simply is
a protein it's a transcription factor
and dela simply stands for the sequence
of amino acids at one end of the protein
in the presence of dela the tall becomes
short you give it gibberellin it negates
della and it becomes tall
this one has a mutation in the
signal transduction chain component so
regardless of the level of gibberellin
it is a tall and we now know all the
controls in this system so here are
various here are some of the gene
symbols and these the lighter green are
the names of all the enzymatic steps
this you can also get a very tall
by blocking the degradation of a ga one
or its precursor and if you block the
degradation you get a higher amount of
GA one simply because it has nowhere
else to go then you get an extra tall
here are a whole lot of other height
mutants this is the wild-type this is
super tall this is a tall this is a
super tall and this one involves
phytochrome signaling the next one is a
phytochrome mutant itself the next one
this is the dela signal transduction
mutant this one is another wild-type on
a different background and here is this
plant where the breakdown of GA one has
been inhibited here are some more
mutants these all come from Jim Weller
who has great fun getting all these
mutants this one this by the way is in
the light this is in the dark
this one I into is an ethylene receptor
mutant there it is in the light in the
dark
this one is involved in yuba quitin
which is the degradation of various
signal transduction
and the last one is a phytochrome mutant
if we turn to the roots we go look under
the soil the it has a tap root but a
very branching root system and most of
the mutants that we worked on here the
lot of work was done here by Tom Silva
who teaches the the plumb physiology
labs and the botany labs here now only
if you had the very deficient gibberish
Abril and very deficient mutant nana did
you get smaller roots every other mutant
of the top of the chute the roots look
exactly the same as this one the classic
things that was discovered about aux-in
many years ago as if you if you take a
plant like a pea a coline plan and you
cut the apical bud off you then get
branching and this has been attributed
once attributed for many years to the
fact that you'd removed the source of
aux-in it turns out that aux-in is part
of the story but not the main part when
you cut the apical bud off actually the
sucrose that has been made it goes now
to the lateral buds and sucrose has a
big effect on growth so sucrose is not
just sort of an energy source it has
some growth promoting effects of its own
this was all worked out
Oh bye Christine beverage and co-workers
but aux-in comes from the top and it was
said that aux-in inhibited the lateral
buds it turns out there is some
inhibition of the lateral buds but it's
not my aux-in itself the timing of the
changes in aux-in and the and the
lateral buds didn't work out
forks in goes to the roots and there it
stimulates the production of another
group of plant hormones called Strega
lactones straggle icons the name is
derived from the parasitic plants triger
and these promote that were known to
promote the germination of strider and
there's a family of these hormones it
turns out the orcs in goes there causes
a production of straggle act ohms which
inhibit branching when the aux-in supply
is cut off the level of straggle
lactones goes down and you get the
branches formed this was a story that
stumped plant physiologists biochemist
molecular biologist for many many years
but it was finally solved about ten
years ago big thing is plants have peace
have many different leaves and here are
the main types and these are all
genetically controlled i am not going to
discuss the individual genes if
anybody's interested we can go back to
it would take too long but it is
interesting that there's not just one
type of leaf you can have this is the
standard pea leaf you can have more
leaflets and no stipules
you can get rid of all the leaflets
sorry and no tendrils you can get rid of
all the leaflets and the leaflets become
tendrils
you can have multi branches and tiny
little leaves on the end so you can have
all sorts of combinations there are also
genes that turn the stipules on or off
and control stipules size and here's
this semi leafless P that is the main P
of Commerce once you get out of your
home garden they have take put in the
gene or actually mutated the leaf gene
to make all these step you'll send rules
but the stipules have been retained
other peas were produced with no
stipules become the idea well if if you
get rid of them here maybe getting rid
of these B there's some photosynthesis
by the tendrils the idea was well let's
get rid of all the stipules as well and
then the light will penetrate the crop
well it turned out that doesn't work the
yields plummet when you get rid of the
stipules so these tendrils hold the
whole thing up and now the main
photosynthesis is being done by the
stipules
here's what it looks like under the
scanning electron microscope these from
knoll ellis and his lab it's not quite
the same magnification but this is sort
of a wild-type just as an example and
here's one where the leaflets are being
turned into 10 rows so you can see the
young tendrils of coming up at the end
of the stem
one thing that peas do that rabid
abscess does not they nod you late and
they do nitrogen fixation and here all
the pea roots covered with nodules now
when I was
a teenager I was into gardening when the
plants I grew was sweet peas and I was
transplanting them and I saw these white
blobs on the roots and I was very
distressed and so I spent a lot of time
pulling them off before I planted them I
only later learn what these were that
they were modules we also know a lot
about the nitrogen fixation process and
its control it turns out that the
control of infection and nodule
development is very much under the
control of hormones and this this
diagram comes from a paper I wrote last
year but notable amongst this is chipper
ellen actually inhibits infection of the
root hair but promotes the development
of the actual nodule okay if anybody has
any questions as we go
feel free I'll do my best to answer them
so we move on to flowering now there are
huge numbers of genes that affect
flowering this is a wild type with no
mutations this is a mutation in the sng
and you can see the difference this is
flowering much earlier
turns out the peas are further period in
the wild type P is further periodically
sensitive and if you grow these they
will not flower until midsummer they
like long days but peas are also a cold
season crop they grow much better around
here if you grow them in the spring in
the cold rather than in the middle of
the summer and it turns out in virtually
all our pea varieties SN
because this was as peace they thought
originated in Asia as they moved into
northern Europe the early flowering was
selected for so that they produced a
crop early on before midsummer and that
is one of the proposals this mutation
led to the adoption of peas much more
widely than would have been the case so
it's a but I won't go through all these
mutations but there's some interesting
ones that are related to what you may
know about the control of flowering
first of all late one here it is in long
days here late one is I'm wondering if I
made a mistake there they're both
labeled as long base I should check that
late one is a clock related gene so
involved in circadian rhythms she goes
here is equivalent to the gene ft in a
rabid abscess and ft is the gene which
controls the production of flora jin' or
the flowering hormone F veg 2 here is
equivalent to the gene FD in a rabid
abscess and FD is one of the genes
that's turned on by flora Jam when it
arrives at the stem apex I can't tell
you no idea can what we do know is the
roots do stop growing
when flowering starts
one of the things I had growing many
many years ago at Goodman
I built a glass sided Bhaiji Plexiglas
sided trough sloping inwards and planted
the plants at the top with the idea I
could follow the root growth I've made
it got a four by eight sheet of
Plexiglas it was four feet planted the
peas filled it with cornell mix and the
peas when they were about that high 10
centimeters high the roots reach four
feet so the depth of the roots is just
amazing and it occurs very rapidly now
Cornell Mix I presume a lot of you
familiar with it's a very light fluffy
mix so it probably doesn't exactly match
what would happen in a nice stony soil
around here but it it blew my mind I
ended up getting long drain pipes and
trying them to 12 feet considers to see
Bob said but the interest again it's
very early on the roots grow and then
when flowering starts root growth
virtually stops so it's all during the
early vegetative part but what these
mutations do I don't know this is Jim
wellas photograph maybe I'll have to ask
him to measure he's going to tell me I'm
too busy with other things I could just
see it coming here's a range of there's
a lot of different branching patterns as
peas flower and here's the basic idea
the the core line stem has a apex which
keeps growing we call that I won a
primary meristem and often the axillary
buds another branch starts and that has
a meristem which we're calling i2 and
they these are both controlled by
various genes that produce signals and
these all have to interact together at
the the
time and if you mutate any of the genes
these genes you get a very different
range of inflorescences so there's the
for example here's a gene head and this
has proliferating ITU's that gave you I
to s keep branching off here debt in
debt the primary inflorescences becomes
an eye - instead of an eye one so it has
some flowers of here and then stops and
this one veg all the ITU's have become
eye ones and nobody told them they had
to produce flowers so here's a list of
the different flowering low sigh in peas
in the interest of time I think I will
skip that and to tell you the story of
an senescence which I worked on for many
years here's Jerry Marx at Geneva in the
1970s there were two centers of plea
genetics Tasmania and Cornell at the
time and we were interested in senesce
plant senescence and he alerted me to
the fact that he had some piece that
senesce in short it's a nest in summer
but not in winter and wanted to know
what was going on and we found indeed
they were senesce in long days but not
in short days in the name of this
variety was g2 here's what you see the
apex keeps growing in short days but not
in long days and during a sabbatical
here and his subsequent in Murphy
working with Jerry Marx worked out that
there were two particular genes that
were in a dominant form that gave
this delay in senescence in short days
it was nothing to do with the number of
fruit because we got short days produced
just as many fruit though if you do
remove all the fruit it will keep
growing and infinitum so it does need
the presence of fruit there's one in
short days huge numbers of fruit rapidly
growing no problem so we wondered well
could fruit be sending a senescence
factor so we labelled piece with co2
radioactive co2 and then asked where the
radio is as if getting into some
compounds that go to the apical bud and
kill it and here's where the
radioactivity went most of it went to
the leaves and it turns out it goes to
the leaves by reverse xylem flow and
that also happens in Apple and similar
crops the the sucrose solution gets into
the apple and the water leaves by the
xylem the opposite direction - normally
expected but very little in the apical
bud and if when we analyze the apical
bud the radio activity it was in sucrose
and malic acid no evidence for a
senescence factor so we then went and
looked at the morphology and actually
what you see is a difference in speed of
flower and fruit development in long
days they the flowers and fruits develop
much more rapidly so they are getting a
signal that they are not getting in
short days and so here the apex keeps
growing here it starts producing mainly
flowers and fruits and what was
happening
is that there is this is the amount
going to the reproductive organs the
amount of photosynthate the
photosynthate going to reproduction is
much greater in long days than in short
days I will skip that and I'll skip that
so we then looked at the hormonal
control and we find that this is the the
amount of gibberellin going to the
shoots as distinct from the reproductive
tissue and this is Chi a1 the level of G
a1 in the apical buds in short days was
much greater than in short days so our
conclusion here too many years of
research actually was that senescence of
the plant is determined by hormonal
changes that direct the resources of the
plant towards c-print
seed production at the expense of
continued vegetative growth and they say
these are two young handsome young guys
working on peas some
over 30 years ago in the greenhouses at
Goodman so good I know it's time but I
got a couple of little neat things that
I thought you might be interested in so
what I'm gonna call P fakery peas are
also a favorite topic for people I'll
call pseudo-scientists so the first
question was asked by Mythbusters
anybody ever seen that used to be a very
popular program on TV where they
investigated claims I'd I haven't seen
it recently but Mythbusters wanted to
know where the plants preferred rock or
classical music so they put the peas in
the greenhouse and in one greenhouse
they played rock music in the other clip
in one classical music then they took
the plant sell both plants looked
absolutely miserable but it wasn't the
music they had them in greenhouses in
the Central Valley of California in the
summer and they were cooking them so
when you look at any scientific report
look at what the conditions are because
some of the results have may have
nothing to do with what they claimed to
be moving so our answer is they don't
care this one is in the last year there
is a woman researcher in Australia who
actually has a faculty position much to
my amazement and she claims that plants
have sensitivities and she clay she
claims she got a gram an oak tree told
her she was going to get her grant and
one of her things says she said plants
can hear and they can hear water in
pipes and she's been on NPR she got a
full page write up two weeks ago in the
New York Times and she hears her
experiment
she puts a little tube of water flowing
under here and none under here
plants a pea at the top and says oh look
the roots grow into the side with the
water pipe isn't they here in the water
ok graduate students look at that
picture what's wrong with it
what a start with it's 1 P and P seeds
are not symmetrical nature they she
planted the seed centrally but the root
comes out on one side oh look it went
down that side oh that's going to get me
on NPR write-up in The New York Times
and this is what I call junk slants be
aware of junk science so sorry i sorry I
did go to three minutes over done but
you got through the entire thing of peas
here's my colleagues over the years that
worked on peas and for which I thank all
of them and that couldn't have been done
without them so I hope at least you know
a little bit more about peas and you did
coming in and they're such exciting plan
ok this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu